نقعد بكم مشاهدينا الى اسطنبول الحدث
البارز حيث وقعا انفجار في وسط المدينه في
شارع الاستقلال تقسيم حيث هذه هذه المنطقه
المقتضه بالسكان والسياح اخر المعلومات
تتحدث عنها حاكم اسطنبول يقول ان هناك
قتلى وجرحى في غياب تام
لمعلومات رسميه ينضم الينا مره اخرى من
هناك همم مراسلنا حسين اسد اهلا بك من
جديد حسين حسين اذا حاكم اسطنبول يؤكد ان
هناك قتله وجرحى وهذا تاكيد كان على
تغريده على تويتر لحد الان ننتظر تصريحا
رسميا من قبل السلطات التركيه بشان ما حدث
في شارع الاستقلال
رفيق انا الان على بعدي بضعت كيلومترات من
من جده الاستقلال وارى سيارات الاسعاف في
كل مكان تقريبا تتجه في اتجاه المنطقه همم
ولي اسطنبول تحدث عن قتلى وجرحى في في
تغريده لم يتحدث عن حصيله لم يعطي اقاما
ولكن كانت هناك حصيله اوليه تتحدث عن احد
عشر جريحا في حصيله اوليه لهذا الانفجار
ولكن الجديد هو انا وسائل الاعلام تركيه
نتحدث عن قناه سي ان تركوا هي واحده من
الوسائل الاعلاميه الكبيره في تركيا تتحدث
الان عن ترجيح ان يكون الانتصار ناجما عن
هجوم ارهابي ولكن بطبيعه الحال هذه انباء
دوله الاعلام التركي وليست انباء الرسميه
الى الانباء الرسميه بعد وقت قليل باعتبر
ان همم الفرق المختصه فرق الادله الجنائيه
والشرطه
اسعاف اغلقت جميع الطرق المواجهه الى جده
الاستقلال من اجل تسجيل وصول هذه الفرق
الى عين المكان من اجل تحديد نوعيه
الانفجار وان تجاه الجثث
واسعاف الجرحى من المكانه المكان المكتظ
ومزدحم وواحد
واخبار الاماكن المزدحمه في اسطنبول اننا
نتحدث عن تركيا بشكل عام
الاولى التي وصلتنا لغرفه الاخبار هل يمكن
ان نعيد مشاهدتها الان من شارع الاستقلال
حيث نشاهد رجال الشرطه وسيارات الاسعاف
التي هرعت الى هذا الحي نذكر فقط انا حي
شارع الاستقلال من اشهر الاحياء في
اسطنبول في الشوارع هو في حي بك اجلي همم
المنطقه السياحيه وسط المدينه وسائل
الاعلام التركيه وعلى راسها قناه دي ار تي
الاخباريه تتحدث عن قتيل واحد على الاقل
في حين وكاله الاناضول الرسميه للانباء لم
تتحدث عن سبب الانفجار وقالت انه لم يتضح
بعد سبب وقوع هذا الانفجار مركز شرطه قاسم
باشا القريب من شارع الاستقلال قال ان
جميع فرق فريقه هرعت الى مكانه يردون ذكر
تفاصيل اخرى هذه الصور مشاهدينا اذا
المبا- او الصور الاولى التي وصلتنا همم
من اسطنبول منذ قليل وقعت بعد الانفجار
نرى اذا من بعيد ما اراها عمليه اسعاف
جريح على ما يبدو ورجل اخر همم جريح في
همم الشارع والاسوار لوصول سيارات الاسعاف
منذ مده طويله لم تتعرض اسطنبول لاي هجوم
هذه المدينه التي حدثت فيها في ال 10
سنوات الاخيره من الاخر كانت هناك هجمات
اشهرها همم الهجوم الذي وقع قبل سنوات
واستهدف همم ملهى ليليا عند همم اعياد راس
السنه
وكان هناك استقرار تام بشان هذا نوع من
الانفجارات او الاعتداءات في اسطنبول لحد
الان لا نعرف ان همم السبب هذا الانفجار
وسنعود اليكم مشاهدينا حال ورود اخبار
جديده عن هذا الانفجار في اسطنبول